mein name ist kein offenbar ich bin 49
jahre alt bin hanauer lebe seit meiner
geburt in der rhein main region und bin
seit wir haben guten vierteljahrhundert
jetzt für reuters in der weltgeschichte
unterwegs fotografien von krieg und
krise bis sportveranstaltungen und der
frankfurter börse alles was man so in
den nachrichten tagtäglich sehen kann
bei meiner ausstellung hier in der leica
galerie in frankfurt erwartet den
besucher und die besucher sind
tatsächlich einen querschnitt meiner
journalistischen fotografie aus den
letzten 25 jahren ein bild über das
gesprochen wurde oder auf dass ich auch
oft angesprochen will ist das bild von
von der hongkonger regierungschefin von
carril am dass es in des räubers
portfolio von den unruhen geschafft hat
mit dem wir den pulitzerpreis gewonnen
haben und es war sicherlich das was
action angeht und spektakulärste bild
das ich eine hongkong gemacht habt aber
auch das außergewöhnlichste porträt der
regierungschefin das lag daran dass ich
einmal bei der pk die wöchentlich
stattfindet und dann geht er bockig
mussten extra wo ich muss was anderes
probieren und habe tatsächlich ein
extrem langes telefonat damit geschleppt
die kollegen habe ich alle bisschen
irritiert angeschaut und ich habe das
bild auch in dem moment wo sie die augen
zu hat und dieses halb porträt ganz
bewusst zu machen wollen ich habe mir
das vorgenommen weil ich mich einfach
abheben wollte
und das interessante ist deshalb passt
das bild auch in das portfolio geschafft
bereut das denn es ist ja so dass für
dieses polizei portfolio nicht einfach
nur das bild bei reuters publiziert
gewesen sein muss sondern es muss ja
entsprechend auch veröffentlicht worden
seien und in dem fall war es auf der new
york times auf dem titel genauso wie der
washington post und die haben alle
gesagt wow das ist im prinzip das
außergewöhnlichste spannendsten porträt
dass wir von der frau in der ganzen
krisenzeit gesehen hatten
ich glaube ich bin recht hartnäckig in
meiner fotografie das heißt ich bin
nicht einfach nur mit einem bild
zufrieden ich möchte mit jedem bild
emotionen transportieren oder beim
betrachter emotionen wecken das heißt ob
ich jetzt mein zwanzigste champions
league oder das sechste wm finale
fotografiert oder tatsächlichen
relegationsspiel um den letzten platz in
der fußball bundesliga spielt für mich
keine rolle
ich gehe das alles mit dem gleichen
engagement und mit dem gleichen
technischen setup und einsatz an wie ich
das bei den großen sachen machen würde
und ich glaube das ist etwas was mich
ein bisschen vom einen oder anderen
kollegen und
scheidet
[Musik]
das bild hier erst vor einigen wochen im
rahmen meiner bemühten berichterstattung
zu corona cupid 19 situationen deutsche
krankenhäuser rettungssystem
rettungswesen entstanden ich hatte die
gelegenheit mit dem rettungshubschrauber
der johanniter mit dem christoph giesen
mit fliegen zu können
mit märz hinaus der uniklinik und
notfallsanitäter die da das team bilden
war sehr eindrücklich diese dieser
augenblick auch so ein moment wo man
dann in seiner fotografie drüber
nachdenken darf ich das eigentlich jetzt
kann ich das soll ich das machen
ich habe mich dann dazu entschieden zum
einen weil die augen der beiden absolut
für sich sprechen diese diese dieses
diese angespanntheit der da zu sehen ist
muss auf den monitor schauen der links
von uns ist ob da wie der
vitalfunktionen zu erkennen sind und
dieses engagement mit dem sie da
versuchen den mann zu helfen und habe
mich dann entschieden ja dass das sollen
die leute sehen weil ja
katastrophenbilder brauchen das ist
einfach so das ist meine meinung als
journalistin deshalb gehe ich auch immer
dahin wo andere nicht hin können um zu
zeigen was gerade passiert und wie
wichtigsten ist dass das für bestimmte
dinge der öffentlichkeit geschaffen wird
die fotografie hat glaube ich eine ganz
gute optimistische zukunft
fotojournalismus beruf der früher so ein
gatekeeper ruf hatte ist natürlich
heutzutage in der extrem schwierigen
situation zum einen finde ich das
multimediale mission filmen und
fotografieren
bei bestimmten ereignissen echt
schwierig dass man das technisch unter
einen hut bringt also entweder mach ich
das ein richtig also dass andere finde
ich meine ganz persönliche meinung
früher hat man tatsächlich mit
journalistischer fotografien auch
richtiges geld verdienen können und
heute wird es immer schwerer
das bedeutet aber nicht dass es nicht
extrem viele hochtalentierte
fotografinnen und fotografen gibt und
deshalb tut mir in der seele weh wenn
ich sage guck mal ob ihr euch vielleicht
ein bisschen breiter aufstellen können
weil es schlicht und ergreifend zu wenig
von den jobs gibt wie ich ihn zum
beispiel macht wo sich eine firma
einfach darum kümmert dass ich immer
gutes equipment habt die sich darum
kümmern dass ich auf reisen die zum teil
gefährlich sind abgesichert bin dass ich
immer weiß ich hab den backup ich komme
hier raus wenn was passiert und ich
bekommen bekommen ein gutes gehalt
gezahlt und ich glaube da gibt es
mittlerweile echt echt schwierigkeiten
und man kann jedem nur beglückwünschen
der ein fuß in die tür kriegt aber ich
sage man muss immer aufpassen dass man
stabile schuhe anhat weil sonst tut's
weh wenn die tür quetscht
[Musik]